parts workhouse I'm introducing my good
friend for rent who is my good friend
I've known for a long time that he's a
smart one did I but he and a few others
revolutionized the kana comics in very
recent years by taking the convolutional
Network approach he and Sebastian song
and others pioneered decade ago and with
miracles of modern machine learning have
made them work better than I ever
thought possible so much for the intro
is my mic on alright alright well thanks
for coming to this talk please interrupt
me at any time as frequently as you like
that's right so I'm gonna get into all
this but yeah what you're seeing is a
video of a bird that used to exist but
then was sacrificed and imaged using
high-resolution electron microscopy and
then this is the wiring that was
automatically inferred from that's right
that's right so the data I'm gonna talk
about today are from three different
sources we have a long-standing
collaboration with the Max Planck
Institute when / Danks lab - my Genelia
campus and then a recent collaboration
with jeff weapons out at harvard so I
just want acknowledge those
collaborators who are providing all the
data we don't do any imaging at Google
we just work on the data and so I'm
going to talk about broadly speaking
three different things I'm going to
introduce connectomics a little bit
although maybe I'll keep that on the
shorter side given the knowledgeable
crowd here and then I'll talk a little
bit about the computer science that has
been driving the progress that we've
been involved with so what are the
algorithms a little bit about the
infrastructure not a lot and then
finally I'll talk about some of the
neuroscience which this progress has
been enabling in particular in
Drosophila and flies and bird
zebra French and most recently in some
human tissue
alright so connectomics it's a word that
was kind of wasted on us there's
different scales at which people blame
you can blame whoever you want you know
as long as it's not me it's it's not a
great word but it's it's it's we're
stuck with it so people talk about
connect omec so for example there's an
nih connectomics project which refers to
really human brain wide scale pathways
imaged using things like DTI or
functional MRI that's not what we're
talking about today today we're talking
about or at least in my talk we're
talking about detailed wiring diagrams
which means synapse resolution and if
you're talking about synapse resolution
then you're more or less restricted to
electron microscopy or in some cases
various particular forms of sparse
genetic fluorescent labeling and just to
put things in context here you know
that's you know a scale version of a
human brain and you know the frontiers
of this synapse resolution mapping are
really quite tiny compared to something
like a human brain so they're sub cubic
a millimeter which you know is something
like that little dot below the text
where it says frontiers of synapse
resolution kind of timing so you know
for the technologists you know in the
field the challenge is essentially to
make you know the dot on the right as
large as the dot on the left right so
that's sort of like you know a
multi-decade project similar to what
they went through in genomics of making
things cheaper more efficient better etc
and in the meantime we hope we can do
some neuroscience even with that dot so
the fundamental question that we're
trying to answer you know from the
technology point of view from the
measurement point of view is which
neurons are forming synaptic connections
with each other and to do that you have
to solve two problems you have to
associate each wire in the brain with a
parent cell body and second you have to
find specific connections and here's
sort of a cartoon of the basic problems
so imagine this is a brain where you
know large white dots or cell bodies and
the lines are the wires right and then I
ask you for the piece of wire that's
inside that red circle which cell does
it belong to
right which cell body there's nothing
locally inside that red circle
which will let you answer that question
right you have to visually trace the
data and that's exactly what we have in
electron microscopy of neural tissue we
have a grayscale set of cell bodies and
wires and we have to visually trace
things now that's not enough to form a
connection in a graph we also have to
identify synapses which are you know
specific directed chemical
communications between two different
cells unfortunately we can do that with
electron microscopy by virtue of
identifying postsynaptic density
synaptic vesicles characteristic
structures of synapses themselves of
course this is nothing new right this
was done for C elegans as we most of us
know in the 70s by Sydney Brenner and
his colleagues at the MRC and so they
took the C elegans they chopped it into
sections the image the sections using
electron microscopy and printed them out
and then manually traced neurites from
one section to the next so you can see
these markings here which are you know
literally how they're keeping track of
where the neurons are going throughout
all these sections and this was compiled
into a connectome and it was you know
finished and sort of formalized by
mitrice's philosophy and his colleagues
you know not too long ago about a decade
ago and of course you can represent this
then as an adjacency matrix and in fact
you know just to prove the point that
nothing is really new even the idea of
using computers to analyze this data is
is ancient so we can go back to 1982 you
know the year I was born this is a
textbook right listening applications of
computer vision technology Ballard here
wow that's amazing I don't even know
that well I don't know if you remember
this page but somehow
I found it it's quite a nice table
actually you have all these different
things you can work on if you're a
computer vision researcher and lo and
behold you know one of the things here
is neuroanatomy right identifying the
orientation the shape of cells from
neuroanatomical data so even in 1982
right the idea of using computers to
solve this problem was clear but the
problem was of course the computers were
just not really up to the task right you
couldn't even store one of these images
much less process it annotate it segment
it and so on at least as far as I
understand maybe someone did that and I
just haven't found the paper ok so so
you know C elegans happened but
basically it was such a pain from every
point of view that you know people
forgot about this for a long time until
maybe 10 15 years ago when not analysis
but really on the imaging side there
were some advances in automated volume
electron microscopy and you know clay
and his colleagues introduced a new TEM
based technique Winfred Bank and his
colleagues introduced a block face
technique there was a couple of
different sort of approaches that were
proposed back then and had been sort of
continued to develop along along various
lines since then I'm not gonna talk
about the details of the imaging in this
talk though so you know just for some
rough timeline you know 1970s there were
C elegans 2013 a bunch of studies were
published and Drosophila by me Chia in
visual cortex by clay and Winfred and
others review studies in the retina
currently what's going on you know at
the Allen Institute you heard about you
know there's a very large-scale project
to interrogate the mouse cortical column
Genelia is working on the whole
drosophila brain Winfred it has many
projects in songbird there's other work
going on and maybe the next generation
of machines and you know very
large-scale projects will try to do
something like a whole Mouse brain
although that really you know is is
quite a significant stretch for the
technologies that we currently can
imagine but that's that's you know also
what makes it interesting so here's an
example of a data set so this is 10,000
by 10,000 pixels that you're seeing and
you're seeing basically one slice after
so just a reminder that typically the
way these datasets are collected is that
you have a block of tissue you image a
single slice of the tissue either on the
block or by removing it from the block
with a sectioning procedure and then you
image the next slice and so on right so
it's kind of like a deli slicer approach
to imaging a 3-dimensional structure and
we'll get more into the details of
volumes like this in a little while okay
so for a computer scientist you know
what's what's the situation here all
right so what do we have to do so you
know there there's a couple of different
things to to think about here so I mean
one is that the storage costs of these
data sets are non-trivial or at a cubic
millimeter image at this resolution is
roughly proportional to about a petabyte
of data you know so whole Mouse brain
would be hundreds of petabytes human
brains would be exabytes and so on so I
mean that's kind of an issue but not
really because right now most of the
data sets are petabyte or sub petabyte
which you know we kind of know how to
deal with compute that's you know a more
significant issue so if you want to run
a convolutional network on every pixel
of a trillion voxel data set you know
you got to think about how you're going
to do that and whether there's ways to
make it more efficient and so on I'll
talk a little bit more about that in the
future all right sorry in a couple of
slides and of course algorithms right so
I mean this is really the most
fundamental challenge I mean the first
two are essentially engineering which
you know are more cost issues than
fundamental issues at this point but of
course algorithms you know humans can
analyze this data but but computers
historically have not been that great at
it so so what are the algorithmic
challenges so the first thing is
something called image alignment right
so this is if you have many different
photographs of the same scene which is
essentially the situation here they need
to be registered into a common
coordinate system right and in connect
ohmic imaging you may actually have tens
to hundreds of thousands even millions
of two-dimensional photographs which
need to be registered and stitched
together into a coherent 3-dimensional
coordinate system and so this is
actually I think actually an
underappreciated problem in this field a
lot of people have talked about segment
which is what I will also mostly focus
on but you can't do segmentation or
really anything else in this field until
you solve this problem and it's not an
easy problem
I don't know clay wants to add an
addendum to that but VIN Freda clay 2005
I can prove to you that your approach
will never work because you can't align
it ok proof by Winfred right so
alignment it remains actually in some
sense not quite a solved problem we kind
of know how to do it but it's it's a
much more painful than it really should
be the next problem once you have an
aligned stack is segmentation so this is
an example of a human segmented neuron
within one of these image volumes so you
know the raw data is on the left as a
two dimensional series of slices and on
the right is a human segmented neuron
within this data set at a cost of 40 to
50 hours of human time per neuron so
it's an interesting situation in which
you know humans can annotate the data to
create what we refer to as ground truth
but it's just too costly to do it for
all the data in the volume ok so what's
the situation here you know in terms of
computer vision and so the basic thing
and you know maybe it's obvious now is
that you know the techniques which we've
had traditionally in computer vision
don't work right they make too many
mistakes so what does it mean to make a
mistake so imagine you have an adjacency
matrix right you can imagine two
different things
so every white dot here right represents
a particular directed connection which
has been inferred from the underlying
tissue so one type of mistake you can
make as a false positive right maybe you
posit a connection that doesn't actually
exist or of course you can have a false
negative right so you miss a connection
that should have been there so if the
state of algorithms was such that you
know our error rate you know in this
matrix was a few percent that might
actually be okay right I mean even
genetic sequencing circa 2018 generates
error rates of a few percent depending
on what you're doing and which species
so from the biological point of view
that might have been okay but really
when you apply conventional or even
state-of-the-art machine learning
approaches off-the-shelf
you know you get basically a maid
that is completely unreliable and this
has to do with basically purple ation of
errors a single error a localized error
in in the segmentation process can cause
non localized errors in the connectivity
matrix right so imagine you split off a
whole branch of a neuron that causes
thousands of errors and the connectivity
matrix and in fact it gets even worse
when you deal with under segmentation
errors okay so how do increase accuracy
all right any questions about what I
talked about so far okay methods okay so
this has been our progress over the past
few years yeah which you did mesh
tomography so one of the you could there
is a form of VMware you tilt the
specimen and that allows you to get a 3d
reconstruction with equal accuracy on
the z direction so why is it people
aren't doing that that seems to me like
to get around all the computational
issues or at least it's a sum of them
not only well you can do tomography of
thin sections in order to get isotropic
resolution in the underlying data but I
don't think that sidesteps the
fundamental issues of large-scale
alignment and segmentation right that's
a pretty big slice meter you've worked
on this it's very very slow to do take
tomography so and the thing about EMI on
Atomics volumes you got a scream at
millions of it okay it's not if the
kicks of she's kind to it okay yeah it
doesn't scale what that's basically
because it's just low and also when you
have wide sections and you start tilting
them they go out of focus so it
complicates the mechanics right okay so
what I mean since you asked for
questions what is the over-and-under
segmentation rate we're so not the error
rate on the matrix but for any given
neuron that you
we construct with the probability that
you'll / well right so this is exactly
what this slide is about in some sense
this is the metric that I'm going to
talk about
I bet just before I do that you had one
question also finding then there yeah
basically humans are very consistent as
long as you subtract noise which is
related to you know occasionally humans
just make a mistake randomly or they're
lazy or you know maybe they're just
totally untrained
so people have different ways of maybe
they're tired yeah so what I mean is
that you can structure a human or you
know effort in order to get reliable
tracings but it's it's a little bit non
trivial right so you have to do things
redundantly over multiple humans and
then combine them but I would say I mean
occasionally you get two fundamental
ambiguity in the data set where even
experts cannot resolve what's going on
but that is very rare at this point at
least in the data sets I work with
okay so metric so so that varies
depending on the method but you know it
can be anywhere from let's say four
nanometers and XY to let's say eight
nanometers to 50 nanometers and Z so
some of the data sets are more isotropic
than others depending on the imaging
methods so we would like to have gap
junctions in most eeehm datasets that
I've seen it's difficult you really need
very high resolution very high
signal-to-noise very high quality
standing in order to reliably infer gap
junctions from at least kind of eeehm
that people produce these days I mean in
principle it's possible with the EM it's
just the current acquisition regimes are
not optimized for gap junctions
okay so alright so to talk about methods
I'm freshmen to talk about what is our
metric right so if you work at Google
you need a metric right and so this is
what we came up with a couple years ago
and you know we've sort of taken this
very seriously in our group and it's
what we call expected run length and
here's the idea if you pick a random
point in a random neuron then on average
how far can you trace out from that
neuron before you make any kind of
mistake
all right so it's kind of like a
self-driving car metric right like how
far can the computer go before you no
human has to take over or something like
that right and so we like this metric
for a couple of reasons first is
actually a pretty stringent metric
because we terminate it at any kind of
error right so you know it's missing a
single spine would actually terminate
this metric right so it's not easy to
make progress on it the second thing is
that it's easy to relate to biology
right so we know that as we get to
larger and larger organisms the total
path length of the average neuron also
increases so what that says is that in
order to reconstruct larger organisms we
actually need to make progress on this
metric visit issue right so I mean
ultimately this it's an average over
structures in the tissue that we have
imaged and if you're comparing numbers
from two different volumes then you may
need to you know do some adjustments to
make them comparable and so this has
been art so this is a log scale just to
be clear here so this is around 5,000 x
from where we were a couple of years ago
and it's now you know around their 4 or
5 millimeter range and basically there's
been two areas of technology here which
which I'll get into the red area and the
green are okay but at a high level you
know for computer scientists it's
important to people couple things in
mind so you know these are very large
datasets and it's really a single data
set right and from innocent sense that
any two voxels could fundamentally be
related to one another so you know you
have trillions of elements you'reyou're
absolutely restricted to linear time
methods right you cannot do anything
even quadratic on this data set and
really you need to decompose the problem
in some way but
even if you have a trillion elements and
a linear time method you don't really
want to shove a trillion elements into a
linear time method so the first era of
Technology in this in this field really
had a pipeline aspect to it so there was
convolutional networks which were used
to predict local structures like
boundaries or are the representations of
local geometry you would form candidate
regions locally using things like
watershed at connected components
applied to that boundaries that were
referred by the convolution Network and
then finally you would glomer eight
things together so you would have
basically pieces of neurites that would
then be assembled into larger holes
ideally neurons by some other machine
learning procedure and so it's
interesting I used to have these slides
where I guess I still have these slides
explaining what convolutional networks
are and you know why you should use them
and the reason I have these slides in
there is because we started using these
things in 2005 and 2006 when you know
really I mean nobody else except for
Jana McCune and maybe geoff hinton were
interested in these methods and you know
I have to say on a personal level it was
kind of strange because in 2007 I was
you know using convolutional networks to
do neuroanatomy and you know neither of
those things were fashionable at MIT so
you know I thought I was really getting
myself in some trouble here but anyway
over a couple years we basically know
how to tell the Pioneers from the
followers the pioneers are the ones with
the arrows in their backs
all right well over a couple of years we
we basically introduced various
innovations to compliment ours to try
and optimize them for this problem
making them 3d introduced and loss
functions that were specialized for
segmentation this was when I was in
Sebastian's lab and I work closely with
another grad student trainee chaga who's
at Jamelia these days and this was
actually I thought quite an interesting
line of work and to some extent
successful so for example this was used
in the reconstruction of the retina that
was published from mort's Helm's
daughter and colleagues in 2013 but if
we go back to this graph that only got
us you know to let's say the first
increment there at end of the first or
sorry 10 to the second and you know
since then progress has been through a
different method so what is what is the
basic issue with this approach so so
there's a number of things but you know
at a high level you can say one thing is
that it's not trained in end-to-end way
right you have these multiple steps
which are doing different things they
don't really know about each other and
the whole thing has not been trained or
optimized jointly for the final result
so so how could we address that so we
decided a couple years ago with my group
at Google to sort of revisit the kind of
approach to this problem and what we
decided to do was pursue something we
call flood filling networks and
conceptually this is very different
actually than the previous approach I
described the idea here is that you seed
a neural network from a single pixel in
the volume and then it recurrently fills
out the shape of just that one object
right so so one major difference here is
that in the previous convolution Network
approach we would first do a pass over
the entire volume predicting local
geometry but without knowing anything
about the global structure for each
object sort of simultaneously right and
then we would sort of accumulate those
decisions into a global interpretation
here we have a single neural network
which is just for currently filling out
the shape of a single object and want me
to think about this although I wouldn't
take it too seriously is that it's a bit
more cognitive right so if you have a
human trace this data they don't grab 18
pencils and start tracing all objects at
the same time right they focus on one
object at a time
and then maybe they have to switch due
to some ambiguity and come back and so
forth but it's it's a little bit more of
that style and so what you're seeing
here is the network architecture on the
left or at least a reduced form of it on
the right it's a 2d version of this
process where the yellow dot represents
the current field of view or the the
center of the current field of view of
the network and then the blue are the
pixels that it's adding basically to
it's inference about the shape of one
object and of course this is just shown
in 2d but fundamentally our datasets are
three-dimensional so this is what this
process looks like in 3d and so this is
I mean it's a rendering on the one hand
but on the other hand you know it's a
literal sort of description of what this
algorithm did and that started from a
single pixel and then grew out the shape
of the object within the datasets
one slice at a time you're yes this is
all in 3d happening yeah different
objects right so instead of just
scanning that's right so we we divide a
large image volume into sub regions
within a sub region we do one object at
a time and then we stitch things
together so there does altom utley need
to be both parallelization and of course
you have to densely fill the object
space so I'm not sure I understand the
distinction so you're saying instead of
just contour tracing you're like filling
is that the difference right in one case
you're drawing a contour and you're
doing that slice by slice and then
you're matching contours that match in
why not for one object so in the
previous approach the fundamental comp
the concept was something called a
boundary map yeah right and so that was
basically you infer a grayscale value
for every pixel that labels its
probability of being either a boundary
or interior right but boundary interior
is a binary kind of designation which
says nothing about the object structure
itself right so then you take that
boundary map and you feed it to
something like connected components or
watershed or graph cuts or whatever and
from that you get distinct regions right
so those are two separate steps here the
neural network itself is producing the
final object right one at a time but
it's producing the final object so I
would say that's the most fundamental
distinction
did the flood algorithm how do you avoid
leaks well that's that's up to the
training process right to optimize the
neural network to avoid that because
that's you know so one of the nice
things here is that the loss function
now becomes very naturally related to
the nature of the errors because if you
start leaking into a separate neuron
you're going to accumulate huge amounts
of error in your loss function and that
was not the case with the boundary map
because if you just miss a single pixel
and say okay it's not a boundary where
as it should have been that doesn't
naturally relate or easily or obviously
correlate to its global effect on
topology so the loss function is
literally just a pixel level
accumulation of errors here so if you
miss a large part of a neuron because
it's based on a single object at a time
that's going to incur a huge penalty
does that make sense
sir so so maybe you should say how this
is used in the training stage right so
in the training stage you know it's it's
kind of like this animation here sits in
3d where you know for each object in our
training volume we have a ground truth
reconstruction right and so the training
phase is we seed the algorithm from
inside some particular object we let it
fill it out and then each time it
completes one of these recurrent steps
we can compute the loss function against
the ground truth object again it's
raining sighs then how many images
reveal yeah so that's a good question
so you basically need tens of millions
of voxels that are labeled which sounds
like a lot but actually if you have the
right tool it's not that hard to get
that much training data how many people
were doing
I mean I guess so for the songbird
datasets the total amount of human time
that went into volumetric tracing was I
think on the order of 400 hours so how
big is the confident that you you
eventually used to do the 3d filling so
the ComNet itself is not I mean it's
actually a very simple convolutional net
work it's just convolutions it has no
pooling or sampling and that's like ten
or twelve layers but that whole thing is
recurrent right so basically there's a
big arrow going from the output of that
back to its input as bad as the notion
of recurrence here yes so I mean it's
all based on human ground truth right so
for a particular region of the data
we've had humans go through and create
pixel accurate tracings of the neurons
so there's actually a number of things
that go into doing this a very large
scale
that's detailed in a bio archive paper
that's that's up and you know this is in
review and also there's now open source
code for this if you're interested this
is another way to represent the progress
we're a few years ago for I mean this is
the same neuron on the left and right
but just from different reconstruction
pipelines where a few years ago the
reconstruction looked like what you have
on the left so things were heavily split
there were lots of things missing and so
on and on the right you know now you
have three four pieces which are
basically correct much closer to to what
you'd expect or want I'll briefly
mention there you know there's some
other approaches here for dealing with
issues and the data right I mean so
these are real datasets there's all
kinds of issues like for example you
might have so here there's in the middle
of this slice here you see like this
shard which is you know some piece of
dirt that was imaged on that slice and
you know these are 10,000 by 10,000
pixels here I'm just showing a very
zoomed up view so the question is I mean
how do you deal with this right in your
in your pipeline right I mean do you
detect you know something that's gone
wrong do you just hope the algorithm
deals with it and so on so one thing
that we've been experimenting with are
an approach called
generative adversarial networks this is
a very new reasonably new idea and
machine learning and the idea is you
sort of pit two neural networks against
each other one is trying to generate
data the other is trying to discriminate
whether it's true data or fake data is
it's actually it's actually a very very
interesting idea and if you haven't read
about this I really recommend taking a
look at it because it turns out to be a
surprisingly flexible and powerful way
to train your own networks and here's
what you can do with it so I mean let's
say we had a slice of data on the left
with some huge crack going through it
right this is just the kind of stuff
that happens when you're dealing with
trillions of voxels of imaging data
using this algorithm we can kind of
repair it so that it looks like what's
on the right so that's the output of the
algorithm and the benefit of this is
then we don't have to do a lot of extra
engineering in our pipeline to deal with
special cases like this right we can
kind of detect those cases heal them
using this type of approach and then go
on so it looks like it actually filling
a bit much bigger than the black part
because if you look at the better than
after you edit this is in the middle
it's a hole that sticks above the plane
of the section fold
okay so you get to see the paper and you
push the two sides of the newspaper
towards each other then there is a ridge
and that's why it's dark because the
electrons have to whereas the shadow
from the whole reason you said that you
can look at neighboring sections still
right so it would only really be able to
do this if it could look at the
neighboring sections right because
otherwise it really would not have much
basis on which does I mean you could
still trade it the hallucinate stuff but
you might trust the results less mmm
okay so this idea of what feeling
networks you know as turn into a
pipeline which is described in that
paper is what's really been driving the
progress in recent years up to you know
a number of millimeters now of what we
call this expected run length and that's
it's really changed what we can do just
with with pure automation so you know
coming back to this set of things that
we have to worry about as computer
scientists in this field you know
storage I'm not really going to talk
about in detail I don't know whether the
engineering
details are really so interesting here
so you have about crowdsourcing right is
that still something that's done by
crowdsourcing well I guess they're
people who are still interested in this
like I think Sebastian is still looking
at this and and so on I mean I I don't
know I mean I guess there's a number of
things to say about crowdsourcing one is
that it's actually a lot of work to do
it all right you have to create this
whole online platform and then find ways
to advertise it and get people
interested so I think you know that's
just a personal decision as to whether
you want to work on that versus just
improving the automated methods
themselves and in the long term I think
you know computers are going to solve
this even beyond the extent they already
have and then you know computers they
just weave through the crowd yeah I mean
maybe not we're good Sebastian and
things are advancing so quickly with the
segmentation exactly what utilidad to do
it keeps changing so the crowd is on
hold
I think experts are still interesting so
for example Genelia I mean they they
don't have crowdsourcing but what they
have is they have employees right who
have essentially become experts in
Drosophila in your Anatomy and that is
actually I find very useful right
because you can talk to someone you know
at a very high bitrate about the
reconstruction results and you know they
can resolve very subtle cases whereas
with crowdsourcing you know it's it's
hard to do that right I mean the hard
cases remain almost unsolvable using
that approach and the easy cases are
going to go to automation anyway yeah so
storage computation I don't want to say
a lot about this except that you know
there's just a lot of you know very
sophisticated engineering that's been
done you know internet companies and
elsewhere to handle these problems and
you know that's more or less directly
usable for large-scale data analysis
problems in neuroscience and elsewhere
so you know I think it's makes sense to
take advantage of that effort I will say
something about computation cost so I
mean the the approach I described is
pretty computation and costly you know
it takes thousands of GPU hours to
process a data set
I think what we've found in our project
and other projects at Google is that
once you've found the solution there's
lots of ways to optimize it so even on
just the software level we've been able
to reduce the amount of computation
required by an order magnitude and now
there's specialized hardware that people
are developing for neural networks that
you know are also an order of magnitude
more efficient so I don't I don't I'm
not too worried that this is going to be
a problem in the long term ok so that's
that's about it I'll say four methods
and now I'll talk about some other
specific projects these are being
applied to unless there's other
questions about methods that I can
address
okay okay so the first project is in the
songbird and so this is with Winfred any
organ at the Max Planck Institute and
Michael fee is collaborating on the
analysis and modeling front so and by
the way I'm not I'm gonna talk about
like I guess two different systems
neither of which I'm actually an expert
in in terms of the modeling or theory so
you know I might have to call ela and
friends to help me out here
but songbird is interesting because
there's both you know sequential motor
performance component as well as a
learning component and there's different
pathways which have been an anatomically
identified within that system that are
responsible for those different
components the area of the brain that
we've been studying so far is what's
called area X and this is basically a
basal ganglia analog within songbird so
hvc is the site of motor production or
timing at least in in motor production
in this system l-man is a source of
motor variability and then area X
received signals from from all these
different structures and it's evolved on
the learning side so a couple years ago
they imaged part of this data set or
started part of that volume so this is
area X now and this is actually a
relatively small volume by contemporary
standards so this is around 600 billion
voxels 0.1 millimeters on each side but
you know we can do this now mostly
automatically right so after we plug the
algorithm there's under a thousand hours
of human effort to finish the analysis
of this data set and a thousand hours
maybe that sounds like a lot but it used
to be two hundred thousand right so it's
really you know much more tractable so
what you're seeing here now is
reconstruction of processes and then the
gold studs are near our synaptic sites
that have also been automatically
identified so here's a synapse between
two different neurites
and that mozu mountain and see all the
structures this was actually the movie
that was playing before
okay why did you pick area X rather than
H BC which so I'll get to that in a
moment okay well actually I mean I will
say that so the reason area X was
charged and the number of years ago was
that HPC is relatively large and to
comprehensively answer the questions
that you'd like to an HBCU need a large
volume whereas their specific questions
which I'll get to an area X which could
be done with a volume of this size so
I've heard that in some songbirds
neurogenesis neurons generated new songs
yeah I don't I don't know a lot about
that I mean I all I can say is that we
won't be able to say anything about
neurogenesis from this data which is
completely static yes but it's a
different part of the songbird yeah I
mean you know fundamentally this this is
a static picture of the brain at one
point in time so even you know the
dynamics of synapses are not captured in
this data and never will be from this
type of data although people have found
interesting ways to actually talk about
those issues even with static wiring
diagrams and maybe I'll get to that and
a little later on so this was a volume
that was taken a few years ago this is a
more recent volume this is actually 25
times bigger now and there's something I
want to show you here so this is a video
of a reconstructive wreath of this
volume reconstructed so this is 11
trillion voxels now but I think you know
what interesting thing is that videos
are no longer compelling right I mean I
think Hollywood has sort of done too
good of a job of creating videos of
stuff so I'm gonna try to see if I can
just load this volume up in real time
I think you're competing with Hollywood
pretty well well the thing is they've
already done it right so it just doesn't
okay
all right okay so this is an 11 trillion
voxel piece of brain which is you know
in some Google Data Center and you know
I think the really sort of interesting
thing now is that why is this
not the late okay
so you know I can just start to
basically click on neurons here right
and see their structure so just the
so I'm clicking on cell bodies in cases
not appear what I'm doing because those
are the things which at this zoom dat
view are our most obviously credible and
you know then you can basically just
zoom in and start looking at you know
the structure of these neurons right and
I don't know actually what you want to
do with looking at them but I will say
though that I mean the few
neuroscientist that we worked with
you know when they look at their system
from this point of view it sort of
changes the way you think about things
and you know in some sense I think
finally the technology for a new Anatomy
is getting up to the scale of the task
although I'm sure prior your anatomist
said exactly the same thing so anyway
that's just to give you a little demo of
you know what really the technology is
capable of now taking very large volumes
and interacting with them in real time
at the level of morphology but of course
oh and this tool that I'm using to look
at the data this is something calling
your ab Lancer it's also open sourced by
our group and is used by quite a lot of
people and connect tommix now and you
know can be used in many other image
contexts so we're checking out if you
look at images of course you know the
real point though is that we can take
reconstructions like this and convert
them into an adjacency matrix which
represents the connectivity right so you
know this is sort of like what tensor
flow might use to represent an
artificial network except this was some
actual part of the bird brain here okay
so no be just showing us a few of the
things you'd reconstructed right no
these two volumes have been densely
reconstructed you know so this is this
you know this is a putative connectivity
matrix pending debugging concerns but
yeah it's it's dense so that's an
interesting thing about this area of the
songbird is that it's not as spiny as
what you would find in like a mouse
cortex or something like that and we
don't exactly understand why that is but
it may just be a biological difference
are you saying like this every single
there's like a very skinny axis which is
well you would normally expect an
adjacency matrix to be square the reason
it's not here is because there's sparse
connectivity basically that's bias
between particular elements so we just
remove that part of the matrix that's
right
so there's a lot of axons that are
coming in and only sending right so we
just kind of collapse the matrix into it
that's right yeah that's definitely
something which we're looking at in some
of the e/m datasets it's easier to
characterize the size and number of
vesicles than others so in clays data
for example that stuff is very easily
visible because it's so high resolution
and some of these other datasets we have
lower resolution so it's harder to
measure some of those quantities as well
the glia are definitely here the
interesting thing about glia is that
they're hard to reconstruct so they have
very you know they're almost like
adversaries within the segmentation
process because they wrap around things
and they have these sheet-like
morphologies occasionally so we haven't
focused on getting them right but in
principle they are they're so tight yeah
so this is something you're in Kornfeld
on his colleagues I didn't buy MPI I
have worked on where as long as you have
some ground truth let's say from you
know light level reconstructions or
something like that they you can start
to associate you know shape with certain
kinds of cell types and then you know do
the same thing at the e/m level
so let me just quickly go through this
here so there's a very nice but somewhat
complicated model of reinforcement
learning in songbirds and basically it
has to do with three different signals
that come into this area X there's
behavioral context which comes from HPC
X projecting axons from HPC then there's
Road signal which is just dopaminergic
release with an area X and then there's
what's called an efference copy okay so
the idea here is that there's a
structure called l-man which is
generating variability in the production
of song and HPC is keeping time of where
it is in the song and then if basically
the bird produces a variation which is
better from its point of view then three
sort of simultaneous things can happen
or three simultaneous things have input
into area X and it learns the
Association basically to strengthen the
variation that was just produced and
this makes a very specific prediction in
that you want to change the strength of
the connections that come from HPC but
not the ones that come from l-man
because that's just an afferent copy and
it would make no sense to bias
preferentially for just an efferent copy
so I'll skip the details because it
really gets a little bit involved here
but basically the prediction is born out
where we find that actually the axons
that come in from HPC almost exclusively
terminate on spines as opposed to ones
from l-man which have a broader
distribution but are mostly on the
shafts and so at least this is
consistent with the idea of preferential
connectivity supporting this form of
plasticity which is related to the model
for reinforcement learning in this
circuit and so this is just an example
right this is sort of a very specific
prediction from an existing model which
now you wouldn't can detect in you know
some reasonable detail using this kind
of reconstruction but really there's a
lot of other questions that one might be
interested in which time do I have
Lehman's okay right much finer okay
second system here Drosophila so because
you don't know a Drosophila a fruit fly
you know very important organisms in
biology particularly in molecular in
molecular biology and genetics but
increasingly under our science also
there's now two different large-scale
images of the fruit flies so one comes
from clay reeds former student debauch
who's been a Genelia for a number of
years and has now imaged the first
complete cassava brain using serial
section transmission electron micrograph
technology and you know it's really an
incredible achievement to be able to go
through the entire fly brain as a single
3d image and see all the different parts
of it and and and all the different
structures there so that is one dataset
which we have segmented now it's two
hundred twenty trillion voxels actually
pretty large and you know there's
ongoing work to assist use our
segmentation to assist human
proofreaders and you know pull out
long-range connectivity all that kind of
stuff and you know I think really this
is tremendously exciting there's just a
lot of very basic questions you can ask
about the organization of an entire
brain that are now you know just there
right for for frame for answering
there's another data set so this is a
different team at Genelia called the fly
um they've been pursuing a different
approach they're using focused ion beam
scanning electron microscopy so here is
an example of some of their data so this
is a in most respects the higher
resolution techniques you get eight by
eight by eight nanometers isotropic data
so here are three orthogonal views of
the underlying data you can see they all
look pretty similar which is one of the
benefits of this technique there's
there's no anti Sox and eyesight Rafi
from the imaging itself
they have an automatic synapse detector
so this is the classic t-bar structure
which denotes a directed chemical
connection in the fly brain if you view
it as sort of a you know like a pseudo
fluorescent label it actually looks like
the molecular stains for synapses that
have been produced in these Drosophila
brains so this is our segmentation of
that data set so again this was the
flood filling algorithm but filling
recurrent networks applied to this data
set there's an example of one neuron
being segmented within the data set and
of course you can then apply that you
know to the whole thing and again you
know look at sort of brain wide
segmentation although I should be clear
this is half the brain they called the
Hemi brain because it's half the
alignment issues don't exist as much
anymore right because there's no slicing
so that's not exactly true so actually
let me just pause this
okay well this will play again my answer
so actually for the focused ion beam SEM
what they have to do is they do
something called hot knife sectioning
which is about every 20 microns they cut
the tissue into a difference lab and
there's technical reasons they have to
do this but that creates a different
problem in that you really have to make
sure you don't lose any atoms when you
do that cutting process and you then
have to stitch together those two faces
of those two tabs and they have like
thirteen of them for this Hemi brain so
there's a different kind of alignment
problem so this is just one fly at this
point five flies yeah that's a very
interesting question well we'll find out
soon let's see so right like so in the
visual processing the optic lobe
essentially this yeah and then this one
so some babies yeah
within like one synapse up screen up you
know downstream from the century prodigy
periphery already things to come that's
good but there's nothing on this
equation do you automatically get this
thing that this is strength or not no so
the segmentation it doesn't know about
synapses so they do have a synapse
detector so they find synapses so in
Drosophila the situation is a little bit
different so it turns out that if two
neurons are connected at all meaning if
they have at least one connection then
often they have more than one connection
and that number can be treated then as a
strength
segmentation gives you it tells you
which things are touching right and so
that's sort of a necessary condition for
connection but it's not sufficient so
you also then have to do the work of
finding these very particular localized
structures which denote synapse itself
okay so so one of the biological
questions which they're looking at here
and this is directly related to what ela
talked about yesterday is something
called ring neurons so there are these
neurons in Drosophila which encode
basically a form of head direction and
so they're shown here in this green
fluorescent image that was taken with
light microscopy and so this is a result
published by the vex Chairman's lab from
from Genelia and what you see on the
bottom right there is a two photon
calcium image or video of head direction
well you're seeing the video of the
neurons but the point is is that the
movement of a head is correlated with
movement along what appears to be a
circular axis of tiled neurons in the in
this part of the of the fly's brain so I
think I'm doing a poor job of explaining
this but the idea is that there is
literally a ring an anatomical ring
within the fly's brain and the activity
along that ring seems to correlate with
the fly's internal sense of direction so
it picks an orientation based on a
visual landmark that's local to its
current environment and then it has a
coordinate system around where where
it's picked that landmark and as it
moves its head activity along this ring
actually moves also so you know ela
discovered sort of topological rings and
her data
you know flies are simpler they're more
literal so there's an anatomical arena
right and so so just verify within the
ring there is just a nerve pill right I
mean they actually there's no cell
bodies in the nerve but we're not
looking at yeah this is yeah this is
just in your pal Norville so it's a bump
of activity in the North Pole yeah I
mean your sofa the cell bodies are you
know they're kind of second-class
citizens just seems to be so let's see
where is okay so this is actually just
pops out of the automated segmentation
this is the ring neurons which are you
know you can see the ring right and you
know this is exciting for a couple of
different reasons I mean
obviously one is the reconstruction
result but beyond this you know there's
basic questions about that physiology
that you just saw right so how is that
bump of activity how is it created how
is it maintained and how does it move
you know along with the flies movement
and you know there's various Network
models or bring a tractor as which
should be proposed and you know we hope
that we can basically resolve some of
the details of you know what exact kind
of model is is creating the activity by
looking at the connectivity within this
region you actually know those neurons
is inhibitory or not do you so that's
that's a bit difficult to tease out
although there's a lot of so this is
where the stereotype stereotypic joseph
allah pays off in that there's a lot of
work going on at Genelia to sort of
independently figure that out through
other assays and in the hope is that we
can you know project that data onto here
just because these these these circuits
are often quite stereotyped this is a
subset this is I mean yeah I mean this
is just a subset that looks sort of
sparse enough to still see what's going
on
it's in fact not that many of them at
all actually it's just these two nuclei
or cell bodies yeah these are the cell
bodies over here so there's like four
them and then the cell boat is arranged
in these two nuclei or all that more oh
yeah that somebody's up there yeah oh is
this one well those up there I don't
know if those are if any of those are
cell bodies that may just be other neuro
pill
yeah looks like fluffy was it yeah it
might be just a narrow pill yeah I guess
I should learn more about okay so that's
that and of course again you know that's
the initial question in this data set
but you know there's there's really
quite a lot of things you might be
interested in calipers
I mean you've put in how many yourself
ten years more pretty much full-time I
work full-time sure exactly but there's
probably about ten others like you right
and and to add in all of the computing
infrastructure that we're talking about
you know a ten million dollar project I
don't blame dollar project with what's
still what we Matt Google already but
how much does Google put in and how much
what fraction of the total workforce for
the whole world
[Music]
I bet the rule to spend 20 million I
mean you know it's a small team at
Google that uses a significant amount of
computation so I mean it's it's yeah I
mean it's not a trivial investment but
you know this so so clay was just
telling me he is he's estimating the
world who spent 20 million is that the
number you would be less we willing to
you're saying Google has spent 20 no no
the world of it well we're about 20
million dollars over the past decade on
segmentation oh they're really
calculated that uh it's not 5 it's not
50 well it's very hard to estimate
because to some extent you know we are
also now riding on advances that are
coming from computer science more
broadly right which you know that which
is almost uncountable at this point in
terms of you know deep learning research
so you know I think it's hard to
estimate what the dollars it would be
put it ok suppose that I wanted to do
another fly break or a half my brain
right right and I say well you guys know
how to do it how much you gonna charge
me for it I mean charge you anything you
know ok third dataset final data set so
this is recently this is work with Jeff
Lichtman at Harvard so you know
something interesting is that you know
my colleagues at Google they they're not
sure about mice and birds right or sorry
even flies mice or birds all right I
mean maybe they're interesting maybe
they're not but at least they're still
convinced that humans are interesting
right so you know
now so so here's the here's the data so
the way this was acquired
you know 37 year old woman with severe
epilepsy went in for surgery to address
the epilepsy and you know the shocking
thing is that just to get to the site
where they want to do the real surgery
they have to remove other parts of her
brain right just to get to the surgical
site and you know normally those are
just thrown in the trash but jeff has
gotten you know has a collaboration and
has now gotten access to that tissue and
you know I think something that a number
of groups are finding now is that human
tissue for whatever reason stains
extremely well for electron microscopy
so it's you know a kind of black art in
electron microscopy imaging in general
is how do you stain too so that image as
well and you know for example Jamelia
have to put in a lot of effort to
optimize it forretress off low and so on
for humans it appears you just grab some
brain out of the brain and then you know
stuff it in a you know beaker with some
appropriate solution and actually it
turns out quite nicely so what we're
looking at here this is a single synapse
in this woman's brain also interesting
is she's still walking around somewhere
right and piece of brain is it's fully
anonymized so I don't think she has I
mean I guess she signed away know what
happened to it right I don't know
exactly what they signed but I mean we
definitely don't know who it is and are
not supposed to and yeah in any case so
this is a single synapse you know
there's the presynaptic axon with lots
of best goals and then there's the
postsynaptic density it all looks very
nice there's a leave some myelin around
that axon on the bottom right and now
we'll just zoom out so there's a scale
bar on the bottom left and that's
basically going to go from nanometers to
hundreds of microns and so one
interesting thing you can see here is
that I mean as you zoom out there's
really no discernible structure so I
mean it's just interesting really right
it I mean all the relevant detail on the
brain is at the nanometer scale and now
this is a few millimeters by one
millimeter so this is a pretty large
data set so this is 500 trillion voxels
now which on the one hand there's a lot
of data but this is
still only a one ten-millionth of a
human brain right so we're quite far
from from doing anything like a whole
human brain and as I mentioned you know
the data looks very nice it segments
actually pretty cleanly so I think
there's you know I'm optimistic that
actually we'll be able to say something
about detailed circuitry and humans
before too long and just a technological
note here is that they're using this
so-called multi beam scanning electron
microscope that Zeiss developed so
normal electron microscopes or at least
SEMS they have a single human detector
this one has basically an array of them
to paralyse imaging either 60 or 90 or
so on speed things up okay so just a
final couple of slides here so there's
been a lot of progress I would say on on
reconstruction and I think that's good I
mean I think you know we don't really
want to work on reconstruction forever
you know that's just a means to an end
so the question now is what do we do
with these things
and you know one obvious limitation of
the current generation of studies is
that you know they're all N equals one
so we talked about this earlier it's one
fly one visual cortex and I think they
will be valuable but you know if you
look at genomics a lot of the
interesting power came out of
comparative approaches right finding
what's conserved across specimens
evolutionarily and so on so I think a
lot of the interesting statistical and
computational questions here will come
from a similar setting right so imagine
we have different genetic perturbations
of an organism and we know they're
connectome or if we have different
behavioral perturbations and we know
they're connectome then how can we
characterize the structural variability
and understand how variation in
structure leads to variation and
function and so you know I think there's
just a lot of open questions in computer
science which need to be addressed here
and I think it's interesting again the
analogy with genomics right where
something as simple as blast which was
basically you know decades of you know
research and string matching that was
kind of modified for genomics had a big
impact and similarly you know there's
lots of ideas and
or science and graph theory which can be
applied here but I think it's gonna take
a lot more than that to really figure
out how to analyze these data sets okay
that's it
just want to acknowledge collaborators
and my colleagues at Google who
contributed to this work thanks art
waited yeah I think so for example with
that Hemi brain data sets I think you
know later this year we'll have a draft
of that data of the connectivity matrix
for that data set which is half a fly
brain and then we're going to repeat
that process for the whole fly brain
which they're currently imaging so I
mean over the next year or two we really
should have something either half of it
or close to the whole thing for for
drosophila at least the strong
connections I think you know if you want
to get to 99.9% accuracy then that's
going to take more human proofreading
time but I think we should have
something that's pretty reasonable
within the next year or two that's
beautiful and very exciting and so what
um so just following up on that question
and maybe on Teri's question too so once
you've got like one fly Hemi great heavy
brain adjacency matrix or you know one
too heavy brains how much longer to get
the next one now that you've developed
all the technology and will it be public
right so I think what we're finding now
is that the methods actually generalized
to new data sets surprisingly well
there's there some specific work we've
been doing along those lines
because you know I mean that the whole
point of computer science is to automate
things in some sense and of course you
know we don't really want to have to
create new ground truth and you know
optimize a method each time so but we're
finding that actually things work pretty
well across different data sets
so especially if it's the same species
and the same imaging method you know the
amount of additional research that's
required to be very close to zero
obviously you need the computer time but
that's also getting better so I think
the main cost at some point will really
be get imaging and you know the the
reconstruction will be will be you know
a minor factor compared to that in terms
of making it public I mean I think you
know that's up to Geneva they put in
whatever ten years of continuous
investment to try and figure out how to
do this so I think it's the standard
plan where you know they're gonna try
and publish a paper that along with the
connectome has some preliminary analysis
and so forth but I think definitely you
know the idea here is that this should
be a resource which other people can
start to try and understand so right now
people focus on these dense
reconstructions of small volumes and my
question is in order to get more at
these communication questions between
brain regions and so on are you thinking
or is there already some people are not
very naive there are there are some
people were already doing not a dense
reconstruction but we are the smiles
reconstruction that can get for example
you know the ratio of incoming no viable
sources local into a connectome that can
tell you something about yeah yeah I
mean I think there's a couple of things
to say about that I think right clay has
interesting thing to say about that too
so on the imaging side if you want
synaptic connectivity at all there's no
difference really right I mean you you
just have to put in the work to image
the tissue at that resolution and you
don't get to ignore certain structures
right so so the sparse person dense
doesn't really come in to the imaging
side unless you're willing to go to non
synaptic to lower resolution right so
you know if you just want to image axons
for example and you know the extreme
version of that would be doing something
totally non-invasive right like DTI or
something at the reconstruction point of
view it's I mean for automated
reconstruction it makes surprisingly
little difference you know the methods
sort of end up segmenting all the data
now at that point you can decide okay
I'm only going to pre fruit proofread
some fraction of the structures that I'm
interested in but so far the mentality
has been let's just do everything why do
you wanna chime in for a long distance
you said it for long distance you have
to do the imaging and that's currently
hard although we and others have ideas
so someone asks about strengths so that
there's a strong correlation between the
strength of the synapse and the size of
the spine head volume and is that
something you can get out automatically
yeah I mean definitely um you know if we
go back to you know if we go back to
this image here right I mean we can
literally just sit here and count
vesicles in that axon that's also poorly
with the string right so you know I mean
I think Kristen Harris has done you know
a lot of this beautiful work where she
has simple parameterised models you know
where you input the interface area and
volume size and so on and so you know
with data of this quality you know
that's you can definitely get that so
instead of just a Jason say matrix you
can actually have something much richer
having to do with you can have a
weighted directed graph what signs up
sits on the very distal bit right versus
right on the slope yeah yeah yes I think
that's an interesting question of how to
capture the geometry right because on
the one hand dealing with the full
segmentation is quite cumbersome on the
other hand just a connectivity matrix
seems you know to ignore a lot of the
interesting detail or potentially
interesting detail besides weight we do
have a challenge I think the question is
I mean how do you want to work with it
right question over here yeah is that a
ton of ignorant but I wonder wouldn't it
be nice to have something that would
live leave a trace of active activation
so that you can
son of a mark mark the circuitry that
were lit up right and trace that so
selectively trace that yeah I think you
know clay has sort of done I think you
know most of the work along these lines
where prior to doing this type of
imaging you first functionally
characterized the tissue so it's you
know you have the the tissue intact and
alive and then you're showing its
stimuli and you're measuring the calcium
traces for specific cells and then you
go in and kill the animal and
reconstruct just the cells that you're
interested in so I think for now that's
sort of the most realistic version of
that you know maybe in the future people
invent methods to you know lead more
information at the e/m level about the
function of the neuron also like really
it looks really darken again
yeah they've been sort of yeah I mean
p.m. GFP analogues that have been
proposed but I haven't seen them
seriously used for connectome extinct
you know every new thing you introduced
into that pipeline just makes you know
it's just couples everything you know it
just becomes quadratically more
complicated the whole experiment because
it's hard enough to sort of optimize
these parameters as it is and then you
introduce something new and anyway so I
think eventually it'll happen as sort of
a version 2 of connectomics but I don't
know clay do you know of any yeah we and
others that there all sorts of
genetically encoded things that can be
made electron-dense what you said it you
look at the tissue the wrong way and
these beautiful segmentations go south
so for for Reve one don't do anything
fancy is he a faithful representation of
the truth I mean you have a beautiful
sin of sin yes Taylor space has been one
of the things which iam has not been
traditionally very great at preserving
so I think classical estimates juicy or
something like 15 percent 18 percent of
the tissue is actually exerciser space
whereas often in iam that we observe
it's more like a few percent or five
percent so people have been working on
methods to preserve extracellular space
more faithfully because I mean if you do
an adjacency matrix it makes a
difference
well it shouldn't affect the adjacency
matrix too much because remember it's
conditional on not just two things
touching but also finding a synapse
right so you also need to find you know
this PSD and the vesicles and that you
know that shouldn't be affected by the
amount of exercise or space so how much
more work would be to tag each synapse
with an XYZ position I mean that's
you're gonna make public oh yeah I mean
so that's actually um so that's
something we're thinking about now is
sort of what what are all the different
kinds of metadata I shouldn't use that
word hate that word
annotations which you know would be
useful to people in analyzing this data
right so there's obviously the geometry
of every neuron we could simplify the
geometry into skeletons right so that's
kind of like the neuro Morpho style
representation the locations of the
synapses any additional information
about the synapses like we talked about
you know the spine head area or spine
head length or and so on
yeah and that's I mean it's it's an
interesting question how to best
summarize the data for theorists and
modelers and you might not know ahead of
time what's the most interesting yeah
metric yeah that will show up so as long
as you keep going back to the same data
set right and extracting it then I think
you're okay I mean I asked Marcus
Meister this question and he suggested
just converting the reconstruction
essentially to you know the neuron
format which people use in simulation
because in some sense that is already a
structured description of a neural
network I haven't really investigated
that enough didn't think about it or to
know more about it but I mean in
principle I can see what video access
transfer to get the skeleton you've done
that already right then you just need to
know the diameter right now you're home
free
you know that we with that kind of thing
we definitely already have so yeah some
interactive queries from the community
strike base type of summary do you think
Google responds to that that help to do
that well I think um you know I think
our strength is really trying to solve
sort of the deep technical problems
I think solving you know the
infrastructure the persistent
infrastructure and community issues I
don't know if that's the most sensible
thing for us I think the Allen Institute
for example I mean they have probably
the best track record of figuring out
how to do that so I mean I think we'd
like to make sure we support you know
that the field moves in that direction
because I definitely think you know
these should be the kind of things that
you know just like in genomics anybody
can download the data you know propose a
new method and then publish it so I
think it's just a question of how we get
there
I just know Tolly yeah so I guess this
is all model free in some sense I mean
you know this to me getting any prior
knowledge about the shape neurons but
that's right yeah sorry what do you
think about the proof can you prove
things they're kind of if you actually
use the for example think and you don't
say given out this are working with very
detailed models of neurons right and if
you know then you can actually probably
if their models are right it can improve
your mettle if not you can improve the
models yeah I think some kind of high
level priors make sense like for example
each neuron has only a single cell body
right I think there has been concerned
about getting too specific because
exceptions are not that hard to find so
for example you know people have talked
about okay well in your arm should never
have a loop right you never sort of
connect back to itself in terms of two
different he writes but actually that
happens you know not that infrequently
so I think I mean I think a strength of
this approach is that we don't try and
assume too much and there are neurons
without cell bodies okay that's well I
said just two cell bodies are bad right
I didn't that's zero body but seriously
body's fine
there must be some bias at some prior
due to their network well they come in
through the training data and so that is
definitely you know the the the network
will definitely try and respect the
training data we just try I mean but
it's so local like the form of training
which is given to these networks is so
local that it's hard to imagine that it
would you know every time it
reconstruction neuron it's gonna look
like you know medium spiny neuron or
something like that right it's just that
seems hard to imagine but I think you
know there's just other methods to
verify what the result is so for example
in Drosophila Genelia has a huge
database of what single neurons look
like from light microscopy and so we can
actually check right I mean how
consistent the two datasets are this is
the kind of a comment but also the
question which is that you know when you
go to the public and it's really
important that we communicate to the
public what we're doing as to Google to
write Google has to have as a presence
of the public and and I think that we're
becoming more and more sensitive of
privacy and there's issues coming up you
know you've got about Facebook recently
they're getting they're gonna get
creamed it seems to me that Google
should put more effort into letting the
public know about Google brain and what
you're doing in a sense that it would be
something is something that's benefiting
everybody gets you nowhere
we're being able to look at the actual
structure of you know how the cortex is
put together and it seems to me be the
interests of Google to do that and
science in general if that would be
publicized at least a bit made of half
half of some sort of a pamphlet or
something that you know you put on your
website that people can be you look for
it with their students and so forth yeah
I mean that's something we've been
talking about recently so I mean that
there actually is more and more
applications of computer science to
other areas of science that are going on
at Google like for example a few weeks
ago there was publicity although the
paper was prior to that about using deep
learning
to identify novel exoplanets from Kepler
data you know there's a whole lot work
like that going on in terms of applying
computer science the frontiers I think
in general the bias there though is that
they wait until there's actual results
before they talk about it so I think
maybe we're getting to that point where
it's it's worth saying something just a
quick thing over here you were a little
surprised about the the exome feeding
back to itself but that in fact is how
we constructs clocks in the computers we
have cells and feedback with dumb bam
bam bam bam right I mean I I mean
recurrence is definitely you know in
neural circuits in general seems you
know is ubiquitous but I guess the
conventional wisdom was that at the
single neuron level there wasn't that
much recurrence okay
[Applause]